on this episode I talk about Pinterest
on Twitter a kosher Latin food truck and
Facebook running television ads in the
UK you ask questions and I answer them
this is the askgaryvee show
hello everybody and welcome to episode
75 and the askgaryvee show I am your
host gary vay-ner-chuk and i am eating
this is a kind of crap I eat now as I
build up my muscle episode 75 guys this
is you know we are almost to 100 and the
final episode final episode 100 is going
to be huge
more details to come India let's get
into the show
Matthew asked you said Pinterest and
Twitter speak different languages
is it wrong to have my Pinterest account
tied to my Twitter account so when I
post to Pinterest at Auto post to
Twitter you have to Matthew it is wrong
but it's not super wrong you know
Automation has a part where you know I
continue to test what's scalable what's
not the reason it's probably wrong is
you'd probably get a lot more value and
we all do it I do it I continue to test
the wrong way to make sure about the
right way for example yesterday I put
you know we have started putting out
pictures that are completely native to
Twitter in the form yesterday's
yesterday's photo of me and AJ you know
hi-5 surround yourself with people with
permission in the old days excuse me in
the old days I would have put the
Instagram link in Twitter and it would
look like crap and that crazy scream
that is Twitter it would have had a link
to Instagram you know and the Twitter is
made Instagram not native upload and I
would have drove people to that photo
but now with the original piece of
content that got a great engagement over
100 retweets and favorites yesterday and
I accomplished the storytelling that I
wanted on Twitter instead of using
Twitter as a distribution to drive
towards Pinterest for the added
efficiency that created automation
automation is great if you're just
trying to make things happen
meaning like if you're just trying to
get the task done but what about the
result that you're actually trying like
why do you tweet you tweet to get your
message out and thus you need to make
content native so I would say it's wrong
because if you take that same pin
whatever you're trying to achieve on
Pinterest and you cropped what's the
crop and we don't with or any none of
Niners are here right dammit you know if
you cropped it appropriately by default
for the plumbing they took my phone too
if you cropped it appropriately and do
better so the answer is yeah it's a
mistake
hey Gary muscle from Twitter here and I
wanted to ask you I have a kosher Latin
food truck at South by Southwest how can
I best promote it and how can I get you
to stop by for a free taste of some of
our great kosher Latin food see you in
Austin you know the best way you could
promote it is to get on the askgaryvee
show check can I stop by yes check it's
double check em Gary since the robots
seem to be taking over in about five
years where do you see the role of
mankind in an economy where physical
productivity isn't really even an issue
anymore
David the robots are not taking over in
five years not even close the robots may
take over in fifty five years and so
since that's so far out I can't wrap my
head around it but if the robots take
over I've got to be really dead honest
with you I'm not worried about the
productivity
I'm scared crapless that the robots to
go over hey Gary its DJ Eve Laurie from
Lodging interactive my question for you
is what's your sales process when you
are working with a prospect how involved
are you with your sales team in pitching
concepts ideas strategies tack DJ I'm
heavily involved in getting the client
new business pitches I'm massively
involved our our success rate is over
the top with me and Bob compared to me
not involved but once they come in I'm
we're on the hunting side on the farming
side I have a lot of SVP s high-level
strategists who learn the business and
then are pitching on a day to day basis
don't forget we're having retain our
base and then we do incremental above
and so the retainer base kind of takes
care of it and the incremental is added
value so there's a little less stress
for me to make sure that's checked off
but the SVP is the senior people driving
the business are the ones that really
are involved in the incremental sales
pitch day in and day out and I'm really
involved in the in the up front locking
it down and that is a scalable model
because if I do my thing and it locks it
down and
except bass then and if I can create it
that it's profitable enough that
everything is upside after that then
that's a good business model David asked
what are your thoughts on Facebook and
their need to start TV advertising David
great question and I'm really excited
about answering this you understand
everything to me is an arbitrage so for
most businesses in the world that don't
have complete reach right TV is not the
best value hence your hashtag however
for a company the size of Facebook that
has reached everybody at some level
they've got two places they can go left
right which is and notice it's in the UK
they can go they can go they're
struggling a little with 13 to 15 but
they're not gonna be able to market to
them on TV and get them into the
pipeline where snapchats winning and
then they can go actually much older
right if you look at the dynamics of
like and this is not much older but if
you look at the dynamics of 70 to 90
there still may be some upside there and
TV has some awareness I think it's
overpriced but when you have a market
cap of 225 billion that's a hell of a
lot more interesting to actually do some
TV and has some justification over
somebody who has a market cap of 50
billion or 50 million or 5 million or
500,000 get it so to me I can see some
justification around that tactic you
know it may cost them a lot more for a
user but when you're left to so little
users you've got to pay a lot more
whereas for all of us there's so many
users left we have to pay as little as
possible to have an ROI everything there
is no one-size-fits-all there is no
absolute statements and you've got to
make decisions for your exact moment
Facebook television ads in two thousand
five six seven eight nine 10 in 2015 in
the UK market more interesting guys
thank you so much for watching the show
we need a lot more questions on
Instagram
I'm calling for it now if you care about
this show at all if you want it to last
pass 100 at all this is your only chance
ask the question on Instagram here's the
link to how to do it do it now it
matters question of the day where are
your parents from you keep asking
questions I'll keep answering them